let this be your next Action Hero we
don't need Tom Cruise we don't need Brad
Pitt let this be body positivity
inclusion that's what America's about
right now
mother God is in my throat
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and welcome to
the first ever episode of hot ones
Classics the hot one special where we
re-watch the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings with the guests who
made the episodes great and fittingly
I'm joined by Bert Kreischer friend of
hot ones friend of the brand just a
friend you know him from Stand Up
specials like Razzle Dazzle the podcast
two bears one Cave of Tom Segura and now
his first ever feature film The Machine
Bert welcome to hot ones Classics uh it
is an honor it is and it's fitting it's
fitting because I mean I'll say it if
you don't want to say it first famous
fan first famous fan first name I'll say
it but I just want everyone to know we
were just talking about this off air the
reason you love this show so much is
because we became friends it's true it's
so cool to watch it blow up it's so it's
so cool to see you blow up well thank
you for the nice words I do remember
just this episode I'm so excited to
watch it just because the historical
significance of it and the whole hot one
story but this just isn't a celebration
of your episode on hot ones it's also a
celebration of your new film The Machine
and you know it never ceases to amaze me
the things that you're capable of but I
am curious how the hell did you get a
full-blown movie made on your own
drunken Adventure dude especially in
this day and age I literally was like
there's no way they Deep dive my digital
history there's no way there's no way
they didn't invent you there's no way
they vetted me I bet they don't even
know what vetting is so I yeah I don't
know how'd the pitch go walked into
legendary I had three ideas I'd stop
pitching a machine I was like it's never
gonna get made it got it went viral got
me selling tickets that's all I needed I
went and I had three pitches three
really good pitches I need kale a boyter
who's my producer said uh all right I'll
do one and I said what do you mean he
goes I I like you let's make a movie
which movie you want to make and I was
like well if you're saying I get to make
a movie I want to make the machine and
he goes yeah why didn't you pitch it I
said because I'm afraid it'll be a hit
and I'll get kidnapped by the Russian
mafia and he goes sold one he goes
That's our movie you get kidnapped by
the Russian mafia it's The Hangover
meets Godfather too yeah done and
literally I walked out of the room I go
what did I sell before we dive into your
hot ones episode I do kind of want to
put it into a historical context this is
what I remember about this so uh as we
just talked about you're our first
famous fan you were like kind of
tweeting about this new show hot ones
and we were so excited because we're
like oh my God like Bert watches the
show like that's amazing and then my
lasting image like the image of this
episode that's imprinted in my head is
you of course shirt off holding the live
mic and dry heaving into the live mic I
was ready I came to [__] my pants were
off I was in bed going buddy this is
your thing yes just get in bed so let's
dive in here I actually did re-watch and
I have some notes so what I'm gonna do
is we'll just direct their commentary
this thing maybe we can chat through
each of these Wings you're right there
yeah yeah yeah it's just sometimes when
I eat spicy food I ask spray throw up my
lungs and breathe it in keep going all
right let's get started hey what's going
on everybody for first week Feast I'm
Sean Evans and you're watching hot ones
no hair and makeup I don't think no
definitely not no hair makeup no this is
uh we were raw oh yeah very one time a
lawyer looked at her operation was like
what the [__] are you guys doing I don't
think we even like had releases signed
and we didn't do any like liability
stuff on the hot sauce it was truly the
Wild Wild West
all right let's start this way Sean the
proper way to eat a wig this is my big
bone this was like because I grew up
eating wings I grew up in Florida I was
in the first generation of Hooters so
our whole thing was you learned how to
eat a wing you crack it slide one out
and then suck it off the bone and they
were so cold I had a hard time doing it
actually we've stepped that up a lot
since then too you're an oddball with a
lot of quirks and one of the stranger
things that you do is you leave these
messes behind in hotel rooms which are
oh man I forgot how talented I am you
know what though you're probably not a
hotel guy anymore though you're like a
tour bus guy do you still [__] around in
hotel rooms like this no well you know
this gave me anxiety because what
happened especially after this is that
the hotel started anticipating me coming
and then they got really excited and
then they would leave 100 rolls of
toilet paper or 20 pillows every towel
they had an inflatable raft and I'd be
like well and they'd be like make us
something I started getting anxiety
you're a true artist yeah yeah I I I'm
about to composition I'm not just so I'm
birthday girl you travel to all of those
teeth do you miss Bert the Conqueror you
miss those teeth Jesus no I do not miss
birth to conqueror in all I want to
thank the woman that uh Scripps had
fired me shout out to Courtney White
Courtney White I owe you a bottle of Dom
you changed my life forever heads up
I'll be doing the arena in Knoxville
next time through Courtney I got you and
your whole company taken care of God
that woman changed you know bad things
happen and you think they're bad right
and then they're good and you're like
like this girl gave me the clap in
college and little did I know had I
stayed with her I wouldn't be here
that's true yeah right getting chlamydia
is the greatest thing that ever happened
to me you know that Steve Jobs says you
know you can't connect the dots looking
forward only looking back you know you
can't connect I can't connect
yeah
I bet Steve Jobs and I probably wouldn't
get along
I think you would I bet he'd be like are
you having another one am I sweating
through my shirt yet yep I was oh yeah
actually there is yeah
this shirt's coming off
was this the shirt coming off though
that had to be a foregone conclusion
right oh no impulse no it just happened
here he's like you're taking your shirt
off and I go out I don't know because
they want to Mike you differently and I
go don't worry I'll figure it out the
best is I took my pitch I pitched a TV
show one time when we sold it in the
room and I walked out and I took my
shirt off as soon as I walked out of the
room I took my shirt off and the guy we
soldered it walked out he goes it's real
it's real I take my shirt off all the
[__] time my kids hate it it just
comes off Florida that's what you're
doing you take your shirt off one of my
favorite pictures and Rogan has it up in
the studio the moment marijuana was
legalized and in La it was me Stanhope
Rogan uh I think maybe Burr we're all on
stage at the store I ripped my shirt off
and I'm swinging around my head and
they're lighting a joint it's a
beautiful picture when you're Bert The
Party Guy and you go out on a Friday or
Saturday night what's the worst thing
about having to try to uphold that kind
of question shots don't do shots anymore
but you know what I kind of like now I
kind of relate to the question because
it's like you know you're like the party
guy but I'm like the hot Ones guy you
know what I mean like the way this show
travels
makes me I think more recognizable than
my profile if that makes sense like I
think people see the clips or whatever
and they're like oh that's that guy you
know like if I go to a restaurant like
the the kitchen will bring out oh like
here are the wings or whatever so I
think like I almost have like the
comedian who does the set with the beer
in his hand thing yeah like I almost
have that like kind of party guy
reputation but it's like a different
frequency wavelength yeah I wish I was
known as the chocolate [__] guy yeah
right and then they were like oh you
like chocolate and getting your dick
sucked and I was like yes when people
travel they always say I want the local
experience and you really took that to
the next level when you became a de
facto member of the mafia on a class
trip to Russia I loved the angles you
took on the questions too no thanks
because you didn't take our traditional
radio interview angle you would say I'm
not gonna have you tell the thing you
would do that it's a really cool
interview technique I remember I did an
interview Sean the other day and the guy
goes so Bert if someone shows up at one
of your shows this video and doesn't
know what to expect tell them what they
can expect I go
it's an arena very few people stumble up
to an arena and go what's happening
tonight and then go I'll pay 750 tickets
for yeah I'd love to sit in the front
row what is it no it doesn't and so I
was like this guy's not paying attention
right but you did these things I know
about the the Rolling Stone about I know
about this I'm not going to ask you that
all right what's this it dude it gives
me chill bumps I remember you'll maybe
you see in my eyes but I went oh he
didn't make the thing I'm supposed to do
well because I mean that's what you try
to avoid like as a talk show host you
want to you'd ask a question and be like
I don't want you to do the thing you
know what I mean like I don't want you
to do the thing so I'm gonna ask this
question to get you off the thing and
then to just think about this thing that
I want you to think about that's great
thank you I want to know about a story
of you traveling abroad that sort of
goes under the radar flying dildos
flying dildos I like where this is going
I went back to this place by the way
anyone listening right now would never
believe what I'm about to say so we go
back to this place that does flying
dildos and and then she puts the steel
dildo in her vagina and she shoots it
across the room and E
Kevin Conley from Entourage grabs it out
of the air out of nowhere we don't know
that he's there he grabs he goes I got
that dude I'm like eat Kevin Conley's
here
shows and he's like boys who needs a
drink and we're like can we ended up
partying with Kevin Conley
foreign
you know the other thing that I think is
like so funny watching these episodes is
how close we are you know like during
the pandemic or whatever every studio is
like you have to film six feet apart in
order to use the space but I found that
I love the two tables and then you do
rogans and you get high as [__] you're
like how far are we away yeah that's an
interesting table that he's got I can't
tell if that's the biggest table ever
we've got it because of Mike Tyson I
think he ate mushrooms and got high with
Mike Tyson and he realized oh he could
hit me from here like Brogan's weird
like that like he always he knows
because he's like I'm that guy well
that's good too and for me you know like
if somebody gets angry eating the bomb
Beyond Insanity I got a little distance
I got a little distance to react yeah
you need a table to push at them yeah
right flip or like a child so I want to
talk about the Burke cast and podcasting
in general how would you answer that
question now podcasting change the
[__] yeah we realized we needed each
other to succeed a lot of times you'd
see people come up in the game young
kids and the older guys would be like
all right man earn your stripes now you
go Tim Dillon please get on my podcast
Andrew Schultz you guys are all
murderers and you'll help me blow up
yeah I agree with that and that's I'm
still doing television yeah deep cable
I've been doing a television for seven
years we got this you look great yeah
I've lost uh lost a lot of weight yeah
because you're in that whole thing with
Tom it's a fashion by the way Thomas 290
at this time but he looks great now yeah
there's nothing but it kills it I can
feel it I can just feel it
and build it in the back of my throat
just do you feel it
oh no it's like
do you feel it
I remember these
let it happen let it happen
I almost secondhand puked I think I have
a weird gag reflex oh I think that might
be a run I think that might be a rental
R.I.P to those rentals you made it
through and you know what that means
what's that 30 second plug 30 seconds
yeah oh yeah for you because you went
the extra mile for us oh my Showtime
special airs in October oh [__] remember
of this year it's called The Machine oh
my God it bombed follow me on YouTube
holy [__] oh my God this is right before
my my mental breakdown oh it is are you
[__] me taking you back to this time
in your life oh my God
I was about to get fired from Travel
Channel I Didn't Know It
my wife was demolitioning my house she
wanted me to get a vasectomy I found out
Tom was making 10 times more money than
I was on the road I got all my dates
pulled away that's right then and then I
literally had a meltdown where I went
[__] and I reassessed everything in my
life I reassessed everything oh my God
a revelation
oh my God this is the moment this is
when I changed my life
oh [__] I'm promoting I'm promoting a
special that bombed it bombed so bad
shut the [__] up Sean I mean that no
this is
wow that is crazy I didn't realize
that's exactly what that was
that was at the moment that I changed my
life it's the reason I'm here today
that right there is I started listening
in my gut and going [__] I'm doing
whatever I want I'm gonna start working
on Instagram I'm gonna I'm gonna edit
videos I'm gonna I'm gonna focus on my
podcast I just get fired right after
that I just got fired dude I was at the
bottom I was at the bottom I was begging
for a job that didn't want me a travel
channel they did not want me my podcast
was doing nothing I had no money coming
in for podcasting I I wasn't selling
tickets on the road Tom was blowing up
and I was watching all this rooting for
him going what about like what's gonna
happen to me if you had said to me that
day
six years from now you're going to be
promoting a major motion picture I would
never in a million
years
look at you now though doggy look at you
now thank you man thank you for being a
friend and and [__] just thank you
and look it now we're gonna watch the
trailer for your movie you had that
special the machine but look at this the
Santa special this is a feature film
congratulations buddy I'm proud of you
I'm proud of you I know thank you very
much seven years ago one incredible
story blew up the internet when I was 22
I got involved in the Russian mafia I
was a crap
did you meet with him how did he figure
you out yeah
loved him she saw him in a movie called
the guest book and was like that's the
guy he had a joke where he said he was
homeless and he was living in a van and
this other guy became homeless and Jimmy
goes you can move into my van with me
and the guy goes I don't know I'm not a
little close and Jimmy goes no you have
total privacy I have no periphery vision
and we both laughed hysterically the way
he delivered it and she goes that's you
and we knew we were making the movie she
goes that's you that's you and we we I
mean we fought together and we really
fought to get him and he did it and I
love that guy I love that guy for the
million times it's a true story Mark
Hamill I was excited to see in this yeah
he's great he's my dad people go how did
you know he's my dad we worked with him
yesterday and the sooner he walked in
second he walked in and he goes huh
see you're taking your shirt off still
huh and I was like well that's my dad
Idina babich doesn't know anything about
starters here in a good story first day
we go to have dinner with Mark and she
goes hey please don't bring up Star Wars
okay I said why because I don't know the
Star Wars thing it's not big in Croatia
so don't bring enough I don't know about
it and I said sure she says in the
market it is a huge Star Wars fan and I
said who's your favorite character and
you can't say Mark and she goes oh I'm
probably Chewbacca and I go do your best
impression of Chewbacca she does a great
Chewbacca do Chewbacca and she goes nah
hello I am Chewbacca it's good to see
you more caramel
more drugs
[Applause]
pickles oh are you kidding me did you
do I really broke my hand there I was
gonna say doing your own stunts out here
I did the majority of all my stunts I
did all the fight scenes I did a lot of
the the fall scenes and I blew out all
my tendons in my elbow and I had a
moment where I was like all right so
what do I do
do I do I shut down production go home
and get surgery or or do I just give my
left arm to this movie play hurt I said
yo you you play hurt and I went and I
adversely I couldn't stop a punch from
my left hand so I just punched everyone
and I'm such a bad actor they had to
edit it out I made the noises for when I
punched people
he looks great I can't wait to see it a
question I do have though you know when
you have a bit like the machine you've
been doing it for years and years and
years you work it out to the point where
maybe there's not even like a single
extraneous word did that make it more or
less challenging to then extend that out
into a full length feature film no not
at all because there's so much of this
story that I didn't tell on stage
there's so much when you skinny it up
you're skinny it up and there's a lot
you're leaving out a lot of meat a lot
of true things you'd sit in the tent and
you'd be in production and you'd need
Igor for the first time and a great
actor a guy named Marco and the way he
was doing Eagle was very like scary and
I go Eagle was playful it really Igor
was like a was funny he was a funny guy
and then I said to can you do like a
little bit of like when you do this then
in the middle go like scare a child like
like uh like and then go back to
strongly he goes oh yeah and he did his
verse it's awesome so it was so cool to
be a messed in something that really
happened because you could fill it in I
had so many more colors to add to the
story yeah and you can kind of relive it
a little bit there was a moment this is
as stupid as I am there's a moment in
this when um Jimmy Tatro is says hi my
name is Bert I don't go to class much
and that's something I said a lot in
college obviously but and this is how
dumb I am I started crying in the tent
because I go I didn't go to class much
my name was Bert and they were like
Jeezy pull it together and I was like
it's my life and they're like it could
have been on like a better moment but
yeah and then what's even crazier is the
whole story of of me and my daughter is
kind of parallels what happened with me
and my daughter as my daughter got older
and wanted her independence and I was
this helicopter parent and didn't want
to give it to her I wanted to and it
mirrored all that my daughter helped
pick Jessica who's plays my daughter and
they were friends and they are still
friends and they text back and forth and
land picked my wife I spent probably 20
nights in a row with Jimmy Tatro at my
house drinking red wine listening to the
Migos I mean the people in on this movie
I Am meshed with I feel like their
family if there's a habit I'm making
machine movies for the rest of my life
that movie specifically was the funnest
time I've ever had on any project ever
in my life I love that well
you know this has been nice
walk down memory lane love that we get
to share this moment together watching
your new trailer but when you see me you
can't get out of it yeah without a death
Wing yeah you gotta pay the toll you
gotta pay the hot ones do you think
anyone wants to sit and watch me be
interviewed no
bro take this shirt off eat the [__]
way do the thing
do the thing do the dance do the dance
this is the thing all right let's bring
in the wings I had a jar of yogurt so I
should be fine
buddy it has been such a great journey
it has tab you as a friend and a
co-worker and a colleague you've
survived a lot of [__] to get here to
the machine to the machine the machine
all right so new segment we're calling I
the hot one's elevator pitch
once that zips in find any camera
and tell the people out there
why your brain
and tongue marinate in Apollo
why they should see the machine
yeah take your time I understand
ladies and gentlemen the wing
is down I'm gonna bask in this heat whoa
it came off
it's stuck on holy crap
this is my body of work this is my
life's work it's my story it's my one
story it's my Stairway to Heaven
support it for two reasons number one
I'm a good guy
that's number one number two
if this movie does well we're bringing
back comedies every Studio start making
comedies your favorite Comics are making
comedies this movie is [__] good I
gave my left arm for it well it's a
little smaller than the right you can
tell right
let this be your next Action Hero
Big Time girls I don't need Brad Pitt
let this be body positivity inclusion
that's what America's about right now
mother God it's in my throat
we're doing a special in theater event
my throat
May 25th a world Day weekend it is from
the red carpet in Hollywood we're
screaming live Sean will be there
ten thousand shirts off beers cold beers
don't be drugs Joey Diaz will be there
I can't guarantee Rogan but Tom will be
there and we're gonna turn it into Waste
Management it's gonna be a [__] blast
my movie The Machine is in theaters only
Memorial Day weekend I am a good person
but thank you so much for joining us on
hot ones Classics this is so much hotter
than I've been [__] I know I know
if there's anyone else you'd like to see
on the show please let us know in the
comments Charlize Theron can't wait to
see the film Paul run the machine baby
the machine the machine support me
Bless America
go visit the machine dot movie for more
information the movie comes out May 26th
exclusively in theaters we'll see you
there
[Music]
you think I'm gonna make it go away
right now